das politische berlin dreht schier durch
und das wegen einer harmlos klingende
meldung am wochenende nach der
europawahl trifft sich der cdu vorstand
zu einer außerplanmäßigen klausur das
kann nur eines bedeuten freunde waren
sich alle experten in sekunden einig
angela merkels kanzlerschaft geht zu
ende sie steht vor dem ende
ja sie schmeißt hin was soll ich sonst
bedeuten warum warum sollte sich die cdu
sonst freiwillig treffen klar
die kanzlerin hat das ganze gerücht
direkt dementiert aber man wird doch
wohl noch träumen dürfen
angela merkel etwa vorzeitig das
kasseler amt aufgeben die ihrer merkel
könnte sie tatsächlich schon anfang juni
vorbei sein
früher als bisher geplant
unwahrscheinlich ist es doch nicht das
zeichnet sich da aber das hat sie vor
was hat das zu bedeuten und wer ist
jeden tag gemüse gemüse neda nicht meine
fresse
was für ein theater ist doch nur eine
außerplanmäßige vorstandsklausur sonst
nicht wirklich die medien allerdings
allerdings ist merkel hier auch selber
schuld an solchen spekulationen das
kommt nämlich davon wenn man als
kanzlerin den wichtigen europawahlkampf
verweigert schwänzt andererseits wer
braucht schon merkel im wahlkampf die
union hat so viele andere tolle redner
ja zb ihren spitzenkandidaten für europa
kennen sie nur den den dings den den
weber der weiß wie man sein publikum von
den stühlen reißt 40 prozent der
menschen in dieser in dieser halle
werden statistisch gesehen in ihrem
leben kontakt mit krebs haben
die hälfte davon wird daran sterben und
das war nur sein einstiegsgeld da kommt
egal manfred weber ist das müssen wir
sagen ein vollblut europäer meine damen
und herren sicher nicht jeder satz ist
bei ihnen pures gold gelegentlich
verrutscht ihm auch mal eine
formulierung aber erst vor zwei wochen
ich die bilder auf mein mobiltelefon auf
meinem handy gesehen habe von den
brennenden türmen von notre dame
ich war traurig obwohl es sich um eine
französische kirche handeln
die ungewöhnlich
wow da brennt aber einer wirklich für
europa die union ist offensichtlich
nervös in diesem wahlkampf wegen mieser
umfragen auch ak cars beliebtheitswerte
sind ja nur noch im sinkflug
annegret kramp karrenbauer und und so
entstehen dann natürlich spekulationen
bei den medien über über machtkämpfe
über intrigen gewalt die filmrechte sind
längst vergeben
die letzten wochen einer ära die merkel
dynastie am abgrund denn jetzt kommt
ging auf außerplanmäßige zilligen
vorstandsklausur das schlimmste gemetzel
seit der entlassung von volker kauder
wird die rechtmäßige herrscherin der 16
bundesländer
vom eisernen thron gestoßen wird der
drache aus dem saarland die hauptstadt
in schutt und asche legen
muss der iren hafte john sparen sterben
[Musik]
oder sieg der böse nacht könig märz und
verkauft uns allen aktien für diesen
reichen kießling wird am ende der arme
rudower altmaier nach brüssel
abgeschoben game auf außerplanmäßige
cdu-vorstandsklausur das große team
ich drücke die realität ist viel
trauriger merkel und ihre untote groko
meine prophezeiung werden noch eine
ganze weile weiter wurschteln und vor
lauter wahlkampf nichts relevantes mehr
auf die kette kriegen immerhin unser
arbeitsminister will jetzt ausgebeuteten
paketboten helfen überfällig will ihnen
helfen mit einem ganz neuen instrumente
wie heißt das zum beispiel durch das
instrument der arbeitnehmer der den
generalunternehmer haftung ist das
gesetz zur unternehmer nach zur
arbeitgeber nachhaftung general
auftraggeberhaftung auftraggeberhaftung
bisher auch völlig egal ist egal
ein überfälliges gesetz ja die cdu ist
in teilen dagegen der
wirtschaftsminister zum beispiel damit
firmen wie hermes oder dpd endlich für
die ausbeutung ihrer paketboten durch
subunternehmer haften müsste das kommen
wenn die keine sozialabgaben zahlen oder
weit unter dem mindestlohn ist eine
riesenschweinerei
in düsseldorf sind 90 paketboten
aufgeflogen die bei der obdachlosenhilfe
gemeldet waren und in ihrem auto
schlafen
das ist wahrscheinlich dieses home
office von dem jetzt alle reden
ja das ist ein gutes beispiel für
entfesselten kapitalismus in deutschland
darüber könnte man sich aufregen müsste
man stattdessen flicken wir alle aus
wenn der vorsitzende der jungsozialisten
zum tag der arbeit was sozialistisches
sachen wow genosse kühnert hier fordert
firmen wie bmw zu vergesellschaften
ich war total schockiert als ich das
gehört habe sie auch ein sozialdemokrat
hatte eine idee
schnappatmung auf allen kanälen
rückwärtsgewandtes und verschroben des
retro weltbild eines verirrten fantasten
kühnert solle weniger karl marx lesen
dass sein eigener parteigenosse johannes
kahrs und er stellt ihn sogar gekippt zu
haben normal nach dem kiffen hat man
bock was zu verstaatlichen so kenne ich
das auch reden wir drüber mit einem mann
der fast mal volkswirtschaft studiert
hätte man ihm gesagt hat dass man dafür
abitur braucht mit oder schuhe oder was
sagst du denn als ehemals stolze
ddr-bürger zu kevin kühn als idee mit
den verstaatlichungen also ich muss
sagen es ist erste kevin von dem ich mal
was vernünftiges hören also ich bin ja
auch dafür dass man die die spielregeln
des kapitalismus mal ein bisschen
verändert
es ist also oder die reichen immer
reicher die armen immer ärmer ist ja
irgendwie langweilig nein wir kennen das
von monopoly wenn einer alle straßen hat
dann wird das spiel und dann gümbel der
abend so aus mit geschlechtsverkehr
na ja das wäre ja auch niemand nein na
also deshalb sage ich warum nicht mal
verstaatlichen bmw wenn es gut gemacht
ist na ja wir haben ja mit staatlich
geleiteten institutionen schon viele
gute erfahrungen gemacht
nehmen wir die bundeswehr das ist ein
absoluter top verein und ich sag mal so
verstaatlichen meint ja so was wir
auflösen
also griff und die privat geführte
autoindustrie ist ja irgendwie von
vorgestern
ich meine wir setzen jetzt hier auf den
elektrischen tretroller er kommt und bmw
das ist wirklich der letzte bulle letzte
bulle rubel also na ja man braucht doch
kein mensch geht nur im weg rum also
zumindest wir uns puzzle fahrer jetzt
haben wir diese woche den tag der arbeit
gefeiert und wir feiern zum einen
tatsächlich eine historisch niedrige
arbeitslosigkeit in deutschland aber wir
haben auch den größten niedriglohnsektor
von ganz europa stichwort paket boden
warum zahlen wir eigentlich jobs von
denen man nicht leben kann weiter als
arbeitsplätze
ich sag mal so von von seiner arbeit zu
leben ist prinzipiell kein guter
lebensentwurf also es ist
es ist glaube ich wesentlich
vernünftiger von jemand anderem zu leben
er arbeitet ja also das können also bei
mir waren es lange zeit die eltern das
können aber auch ehepartner seien später
mal die kinder vielleicht also da muss
man die verantwortung weiter geben das
finde ich vernünftiger als diese
mitleidstour höhe wie verdienst wenig
die paketboten verdienen weniger habe
ich meine was machen sie dann auch groß
dann stellen ihre pakete zu lieblos
anonym
und persönlich sagt keiner nach
eigeninitiative ich meine ist die
normalste sache der welt dass sie so ein
paket auch mal aufmachen und mir was
raus nehmen wir uns selber ein bild zu
verhökern aber da kommt nichts so und
dann dann regen sie sich auf 800 euro
ist wenig also ich sage mal so 800 euro
dann ist meine erfahrung davon kann man
sehr gut leben als jetzt nicht in
deutschland aber albanien
so werden jetzt täglich pendeln zu viel
ist dann muss man sich auch mal fragen
dann hat man also es wird doch niemand
gezwungen paketbote zu werden nein ich
meine hätten sie etwas gelernt oder
hätten sie studiert dann könnten sie
heute taxi fahren ja
schuld am elend in der paketbranche sind
natürlich auch wir verbraucher weil wir
immer mehr nur noch online bestellen und
habe ich gelesen jedes sechste paket
wird retour geschickt meistens kostenlos
müssten wir alle vor dem bestellen mehr
nachdenken also das ist ja dass dieses
hin und her ich glaube es wäre
wesentlich wäre wesentlich ökologischer
wenn man das ganze bestellt gleich
direkt im garten verbrannt
aber ich weiß es von meiner frau die
denke dass sehr viel nach also wenn sie
ihre klamotten bestellt dann wird das
genau abgecheckt da geht die größen und
dass man das alles kombinieren kann
das problem ist nur das paket das kommt
der erst vier tage später
und in der tat hat er natürlich wieder
so viel zugenommen hans de schreibt über
die heute show ihr seid die richtigen
links [ __ ] besonders welke die
stradivari unter den arschgeigen bei
euch smileys freudentränen freudentränen
freudentränen freund rennkurs mit herz
vielen dank für ihr freundliches
feedback für ein exklusives geigensolo
von oliver welke
abonnieren sie den kanal